tras menos de un mes en el cargo mustafá
depp renunció como primer ministro de
líbano
wade en la formación de un gobierno con
las especificaciones requeridas estaba
condenada al fracaso y pese a mi
preocupación por la unidad nacional con
su constitucionalidad y credibilidad me
excuso de la tarea de formar un gobierno
deseando a la persona que sea elegida
para llevar a cabo esta tarea
desalentadora y a quienes lo seleccionen
toda la suerte para enfrentar los
peligros que vive nuestro país gente y
economía el ex funcionario aseguró que
el acuerdo entre los partidos libaneses
que se logró hace un mes con la
intervención del presidente francés
emmanuel macrón ya no existe
la misión de adif era formar gobierno
para mitad de septiembre guadina anna
tequila también pido disculpas al pueblo
libanés que sufrió y sigue sufriendo por
no poder conformar un equipo de reforma
para trabajar con la iniciativa del
presidente francés por el pueblo libanés
el líder sunita y ex primer ministro
saad al hariri y el chiíta y portavoz
del parlamento nabih berri lamentaron lo
ocurrido y aseguraron que continuarán
trabajando de acuerdo con la iniciativa
el líbano el poder es compartido entre
cristianos y musulmanes actualmente la
nación se encuentra sumida en la peor
crisis económica desde la guerra civil
que finalizó en 1990 los bancos están
paralizados y la moneda va en caída
libre el 45% de la población vive en la
pobreza
la situación se ha visto agravada desde
las explosiones que vivió el puerto de
beirut en agosto y septiembre de acuerdo
con el banco mundial las pérdidas por
los sucesos rondarían los 10 mil
millones de dólares las conversaciones
con el fondo monetario internacional
sobre un paquete de rescate se
estancaron este año una de las primeras
tareas del nuevo gabinete será reiniciar
las negociaciones